okay sorry if you have to use one of
these they're not as good as the others
but they still work and I gave out all
the other ones this is all I'm gonna use
so very quickly it says this is it's not
swear they are a construction thing okay
so it says drawer vitac would try with
an angle of 35 degrees okay you're right
so is he's where you begin just take one
of these then you can sit down because
you should have come five minutes ago
whatever else game okay you should have
a straight edge of some kind either one
Potter you protect up or remove whatever
stop by drawing a line any line okay now
we we want a right angle because it's a
right angle triangle right so off of
this line I'm going to draw up a right
angle like this okay so if you want
alternatively you can get at your
protractor and you can put the uh the
central point of the projector there and
the ninety degrees will be straight up
okay but ninety degrees we're pretty
good at visualizing right angles so you
may be I would just so slap this up and
you'll get a line like so okay now I
don't know how far this is going to be
okay so I've kind of drawn them of I
don't know what length they are and it
kind of doesn't matter
okay now you reach for your protractor
okay now the future when yours the same
orientation as mine kind of like a
letter L okay where I would put the
point of the projector is now on the
idea I can't dummy in here so when you
place it there you want to read up okay
and so I'm gonna draw a bit bigger
because too small for you to visualize
so you've got your nine degrees up here
and that means 45 will be somewhere over
okay whatever 135 degrees right 35 okay
so I'm guessing faith I'll be somewhere
around here okay
so our line looks like this this will
have to do so you placed the center
point on the end of that line okay so
you want to read up to 35 right so this
is the angle we're going to draw in a
second okay so we draw tracted there I
would put a point there like so and then
you can take your protractor away okay
now I'm gonna try and do it here it's
gonna be really small but it should
still work okay
now having placed that point on there
now you're just gonna join the end here
up to here until it meets that other
vertical line that we drew okay so
what's the Marissa guess
yeah I'll just reach
well I lost it a bit the end time to
hold on was longer than your arm but
anyway there you go okay so number one
it's right angle because that's what we
started with and number two we use the
protractor and we've got this 35 degree
angle there okay
manses measure the length of each side
now remember we just sort of drool eyes
that we didn't measure it at all so I
assume everyone's got a different size
triangle like between each other and to
me but doesn't matter the whole point of
the trigonometric ratios is that what
we're going to get will be the same
whatever the lengths of these are okay
so you get at your ruler I'm going to
measure mine and measure out the sides
which sites they want all of them okay
so let's measure it
okay so here's what I had measured it I
got kind of lucky actually if I made it
any bigger because this is only made
along so good thing I managed to fit my
name you have some different
measurements okay I want you to put
yours in as well and let's continue on
it says use the length measurements to
calculate and then it gives us these
three measures sine cos and tan all of
the ankle 35 degrees like so okay
use the length measurements to calculate
so where we started was to say well sine
is just opposite on hypotenuse right
um here's woman off cutter this off yet
hands up
leave it on oh that's that's okay sorry
people who are I'll turn off in a five
minutes thank you so sorry where were we
we used our mnemonic device like so to
remember which ratios match up to which
sides okay so let's write it off here we
go
sine is opposite by hypotenuse so my
triangle right I've got officer on
hypotenuse maybe we'll just mark them in
quickly you've got the opposite side
over here here's the hypotenuse and here
is the adjacent side okay so according
to my measurements which is just an
approximation but they're pretty good
I've got 51 on 19 3
I'll leave that for now closed 35 is
according to the new one it's adjacent
on the hypotenuse X this ratio
78 on 93 and then this one's gonna be
the last ratio opposite on adjacent 51
on 78 okay now just by coincidence all
my numbers introduced by three I totally
did not then intend out but anyway um
you're going to get some other values
okay could someone give me an example of
what they got for sign 35 what what
numbers did you get yes okay three over
five point five okay I'm someone else
what else
so what else measured already anyway yep
4 over 7
can I get one more yep six over ten
point five okay now this is a bit hard
to understand because it's all in
fractions right I want to compare all of
these numbers together so we do
calculate there there's mine let's
convert all these to decimal okay
because that'll be a bit easier to run
compare them now what I've got was 51
divided by 90 degree which is 0.55
that's two decimal places uh who is that
Sapir what was yours in decimal good is
it someone else why help me out and
Jacob you can work out yours as well and
Amy what's your cut then me
and Peter can you work out one for me
anyone yep
yeah decimal place seven okay yep yep
five four five Simon find that up that's
okay and who's got the last one yep okay
so this is good
um they're all slightly different and
that was because what we mentioned
before that you know we're easy a ruler
like I mean for me I just went to the
nearest centimeter up okay but we're all
in the same ballpark and you can do the
same for these you can get decimal now
okay now the next part I think we're on
to Part D says use a calculator to
obtain these values okay so this is our
C so now let's do
312 okay so now your calculator you can
actually discover it science it's right
there in the middle okay 35 and you'll
get number seven so we had a Jacob and
Amy's measurements are clearly better
than mine and Sir pairs but there you go
we're all in the right ballpark right
sorry that's really messy okay so that's
what it's actually in this more decimal
places after that but that's what it's
actually equal to if we drawn it really
precisely okay and of course you can
repeat the process for these didn't ask
you to do something else that's it okay
it's that answer your question for which
part you mean this part yeah yeah I mean
they're all gonna be roughly this but
because you know for example I don't
even have millimeters on my thing so I
can't visual sure okay right so I mean
this question you wouldn't really get in
a test the point of this question is to
illustrate that what you'll get your
calculator is giving you right it's not
just random it comes from this if you
could measure it precisely
right now we can't but even without
inaccurate measurements we can still
illustrate look for different triangles
gave us all those measurements but the
ratios are pretty much all the same all
the same the only difference is it just
accuracy okay so I wouldn't worry about
oh it's a state right or wrong this is
what you actually get expect to use